Tony wanted to know if radiation treatment can cause hard bumps on the skin like keyloids
or something.
They haven't changed in color or size so the oncologists isn't worried but they aren't
sure what they are.
Um, yes, it can.
So, uh, Indol, three carbonyl, thank you.
Yes, it can.
So one of the dangers of radiation therapy is you could end up with skin cancer.
So, um, I would use some essential oils on that, um, make sure if it's a hot oil that
you're adding a carrier oil to it, um, adding some different creams to that.
Most oncologists post radiation will recommend, um, some post radiation cream.
Um, that's anti-inflammatory, many times the steroid cream of things is recommended.
But I would definitely use some, um, some essential oils which takes on it.